à faire l'interview self destruct alors
lambert c'est quoi votre plus gros bide
hs on était venu faire la promotion ici
ça a été dur ça hs avait pas marché du
tout ça fait comment hs sa marque et
tout le monde le film dans lequel vous
jouez que vous n'osez pas regarder même
quand il passait la télé rien ah non
j'ai pas encore parlé qui qui risque un
jour de passer à la télévision message
évoqué sa fille qui s'appelle new
generation et ça c'est le premier film
que j'ai fait prêts à les premiers films
que j'ai faits c'est un opéra rock dans
lequel je fais le chef des mods et il y
avait des rockers contre les modes et
c'est une sorte de comédie musicale
façon années début année 87 et les
sharks un peu ce qu'il est éliminé et
les rockers moi je les chefs des mines
est naturellement et gb chorégraphie de
danse voir le film mais ça c'est un truc
mais un dvd on peut voir un jour ce truc
va débarquer un jour ce tribun débarquer
toi tu partiras lâche pas il vous je
quitte mon petit ami tu peux tu engagé
en à un pote qui peut de brancher dans
quel genre de rôles êtes-vous nul je
suis nulle dans l'est un rôle de
d'action mail un bruce willis quoi ça
c'est catastrophique
ça c'est vraiment je sais faire des
trucs fous des jeux c'est quand même
faire du sport etc
mais si je suis particulièrement nul
surtout quand il faut jouer moi même
quand on me demande ne change rien c'est
exactement ça que je la saisirai c'est
terrible je sais pas qui je suis et zé
ça m'ennuie totalement est-ce qu'il
arrive lambert quand vous prennent pour
quelqu'un d'autre dans la rue vaneau
mère m'a toujours poursuivi en mesure
l'an christophe christophe maé d'année
le problème c'est qu'on hurle et
christophe christophe et quand je disais
je ne m'appelle pas à christophe funds
et mais si j'ai vu des films et ont cité
mais est-ce que vous avez déjà été
refusée à un casting tout le temps j'ai
insulté refusé et là par exemple j'ai
fait tout ce que j'ai fait tout ce que
j'ai pu pour entrer dans davinci code
mais parler un porte parle et cheney ses
seins et l'albinos le tout tiendra pas
voulu de moi mais ils n'ont pas c'était
infernal est vraiment est-ce que je suis
très honnête par rapport à ça j'ai tout
fait pour être dans le film parce que
c'était pratique c'est un film américain
qui sont à paris
pas loin de chez moi au lourd et tout ça
et non pas vous
sk du tournage que vous avez commencé et
durant lesquelles on a dû vous remplacer
parce que vous n'étiez pas assez bon
j'en ai rêvé bien souvent c'est vrai nom
mng tension c'est d'aller jusqu'au bout
c'est bien cela dit n'a pas des rôles
très long ça serait pareil ça chauffe
est ce qu'un producteur a déjà exigé une
doublure corps quand vous deviez jouer
un rôle de nu mais moi je n'exige et
parce que je suis super pudique
ah oui en fait mais maintenant j'ai
envie de me montrer parce que je suis un
peu devenu exhibo en vo cours d'essai
c'est un truc avec lé avec l'âge quoi
début on est super public apprend on a
envie de se montrer la plus personne de
vous voir vrai qu'on voit pierre arditi
tout nus l'un souvent mais on l'a vu
c'est vrai que maintenant ils ont plutôt
tendance à aller aller me remplacer mais
en me demandent moins de sur des scènes
de nu c'est vrai j'ai déjà pensé
chirurgie esthétique lambert j'y pense
tout le temps thierry qu'est-ce que vous
supportez pas chez vous je supporte pas
le fait de pas me supporter je ne
supporte pas mon
mon auto flagellation permanent et se
mars je vous donne vraiment la wii mais
c'était le bon test effectivement l'ag
médaille d'or absolument parfait c'est
quoi votre principal défaut c'est
l'impatience 1
qu'est-ce que vous êtes incapable de
faire vraiment je suis incapable d'avoir
un sac ranger c'est à dire qu'il ya des
scènes effrayant dans tous les aéroports
toutes les gares du monde où je suis à
quatre pattes je deserces entièrement le
singe trouver le passeport le billet
d'avion les clés la qualité que je te
vois tu as quatre voitures
c'est le seul moyen pour le trouver le
jour où l'attend du monde j'espère un
truc en secret je n'étais pas obligé
justice est dit et c'est le seul moyen
trouvé par le biais des sites ont été de
mettre de l'ordre
pourquoi est-ce qu'on vous quitte en
général parce que je suis trop obsédé
par mon travail
ah oui et que j'aimerai que j'y accorde
énormément d'attention comme brian
joubert
bah oui mais c'est normal aussi en deux
mois
je n'étais pas d'arriver niall horan
vous êtes déjà surpris à être lâche
souvent disons que j'aime pas mettre les
gens dans des situations mal à l'aise et
donc souvent je ment par omission
ah vous êtes souvent obligé de mentir je
ne m'en pour pas faire du mal c'est vrai
ça arrive ça m'arrive souvent c'est vrai
parce que je n'ai pas envie que les gens
sentent mal mais du coup j'ai
jean-pierre les situations très
régulièrement
heureusement temps non mais tu oublies
fort c'est bien aussi
on pensait que vous méritez tout ce qui
vous était arrivé lambert mais qu'est ce
qui m'est arrivé non je mérite pas
autant d'adversité ça c'est clair mais
je trouve que c'est difficile parfois
mais je suis un gr j'ai eu un parcours
quand même très privilégiée ça va là
vous avez atteint une certaine sérénité
non non en 10 ans ce qui est assez
rigolo c'est que par exemple dans les
projets de cette année et l'année
prochaine j'ai réussi à mettre de façon
assez compact toutes les aspirations que
j'avais en tout cas professionnelle mais
je suis d'accord